[موسيقى]
يُطلق عليها اسم مدينة الأكتاف العريضة
شيكاغو ، وهي ترتفع بشكل مهيب من
الغرب الأوسط الأمريكي ، والموقف
هنا صاخب للغاية ومرحب بأي شخص
يرغب في البحث عن أحلام كبيرة
[موسيقى]
لا توجد مدينة مثلها تمامًا هناك
في الحقيقة ليست نيويورك كبيرة
سان فرانسيسكو جميلة لوس أنجلوس
ممتعة ،
ميامي مختلفة ولكن شيكاغو انظر فقط
إلى الحجم الهائل لهذا النوع من
المباني ، إنه في وجهك وهو
يستحوذ على أننا هنا ونحن
مهمون حقًا  من المدينة التي
عشت فيها في شيكاغو
طوال حياتي أحب جيم سامويلسون
كل شيء تتجاوز شيكاغو
الهوس الشخصي ،
فهو المؤرخ الثقافي الرسمي للمدينة ،
وهو الشخص المثالي لإظهار
هذه المباني المهيبة الحمض النووي
لهذه المدينة القاسية ولكنها رومانسية أيضًا
إنها مدينة  لا تقلق بشأن
اتباع القواعد من نواحٍ عديدة ،
فالمدن التي ولدت نتيجة كارثة
وضرورة تقع في
الغرب الأوسط الأمريكي ، وقد قفز المؤسسون على
إمكانية أن يكونوا مركزًا ل  بسبب
أمريكا ثم في عام 1871 ، قضت حريق شيكاغو العظيم
على المدينة كلها ، وهي
عملية إعادة بناء تحتاج إلى
مهندسين معماريين ومن يأتون ولكن
الأشخاص المرتدين لديهم فكرة مختلفة
عن الشكل الذي يجب أن تبدو عليه الهندسة المعمارية
وفي هذه الحالة زرعوا
بذرة للهندسة المعمارية الحديثة
ومن الرماد مرة أخرى استفد من
الشدائد ، أول ناطحة سحاب في
العالم وواحدة من العديد من المدن التي
تُعرف الآن بهذه المدينة ، يتدفق المهندسون المعماريون
المفكرون إلى هذه المدينة
إذا كان فن العمارة المقتبس هو الفن الذي
نعيش فيه  صحيح ،
يجب أن تكون شيكاغو معرضًا فنيًا مليئًا
بالروائع